Narrator:
BACK AT BUG BUNKER HQ...
WHAT THE HECK IS THIS?
Narrator:
...VALERIE, RACHEL AND JESSE
ARE TESTING AN ADHESIVE MYTH
FOR THE AGES.
IS IT POSSIBLE TO BUILD
A GIANT-SIZED GLUE TRAP
AND CATCH A HUMAN?
THIS ONE
IS DEFINITELY STICKY.
Adam: AND AFTER TESTING
AND THEN ELIMINATING
A BUNCH OF
STORE-BOUGHT OPTIONS,
BECAUSE THEIR
MECHANICAL PROPERTIES
JUST WEREN'T UP TO THE SCALE
OF A HUMAN BEING,
THE MYTHBUSTERS WENT
FOR SOME MID-SCALE TESTS...
OH, MY GOD.
DEFINITELY STICKY.
...AND SETTLED UPON A GLUE
THEY THINK IS PERFECT
AND JUST MIGHT SUCCEED AT THIS.
Narrator: AND THAT
IS A WHOPPING 60 GALLONS
OF OFF-THE-SHELF RODENT GLUE,
A PROPRIETARY FORMULA
THAT COMBINES LINSEED OIL
AND POLYURETHANE DERIVATIVES
FOR VISCOSITY
AND ADHESIVE POWER.
MY FAVORITE PART IS THAT THEY
ENDED UP WITH A GLUE
ACTUALLY MEANT FOR
CATCHING ANIMALS --
IN THIS CASE, RODENTS.
OH, MY GOSH.
I CAN'T EVEN TELL YOU
HOW STICKY THIS STUFF IT.
IT IS REALLY GROSS,
AND I FEEL LIKE
IT JUST MIGHT WORK.
AH, I WAS LICKING
A DIFFERENT FINGER.
GOT YOU.
YOU UNDERSTAND,
IF WE GET STUCK IN THIS,
WE ARE STUCK FOR GOOD.
SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR THE FULL-SCALE TEST.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
WELCOME TO THE BUSTER MOTEL,
WHERE MYTHBUSTERS GO IN, AND
THEY MIGHT JUST NOT MAKE IT OUT.
Narrator: SUITABLY ATTIRED...
WELCOME TO THE GUN SHOW.
Narrator: ...VALERIE VOLUNTEERS
TO MAKE THE FIRST RUN.
-GOOD LUCK.
-THANK YOU.
Valerie: I'M ABOUT TO RUN
THROUGH 450 POUNDS OF GLUE.
ALL RIGHT.
CUE THE LIGHTS.
I'VE HAD NIGHTMARES ABOUT THIS,
BUT IT'S TIME TO FACE THEM.
Narrator:
AND WITH CAUTIONARY CONFIDENCE,
VALERIE TAKES THE PLUNGE.
UGH!
RUN NUMBER ONE,
IN THREE, TWO, ONE.
YEAH!
AW! NO!
Narrator: ONE SHOE DOWN.
Adam: UH-OH!
TWO HANDS DOWN.
-WE HAVE A STUCK BUG.
-CAN YOU STAND UP?
Narrator:
AND VALERIE IS OUT OF THE RACE.
I AM NOT MOVING.
-WHOA.
-COME ON!
WOW!
OH, MY GOSH.
VALERIE!
Valerie: I SWEAR TO GOD.
I CAN'T MOVE.
Narrator:
ROUND ONE IS CONCLUSIVE.
OH, THERE WE GO,
AWESOME.
THE GLUE KNOCKED
VALERIE'S SOCKS OFF.
Valerie: I LIKED THAT SOCK.
YEAH!
AW! NO!
Valerie: THAT CAUGHT ME.
THAT TOTALLY CAUGHT ME.
-TOTALLY CAUGHT YOU.
-TOTALLY.
WOW.
Narrator:
ROUND TWO, RACHEL IS UP.
I HAVE A TECHNIQUE --
THE TWINKLE-TOES.
I THINK IT WILL WORK BETTER
BECAUSE THE SURFACE AREA
IS LESS,
AND I'LL BE ABLE TO PULL IT OUT
QUICKER,
SO I THINK IT WILL WORK.
MARK MY WORDS.
ALL RIGHT.
[ CHUCKLES ]
HUMAN TRIAL
OF OUR BUG TRAP.
IN THREE, TWO, ONE.
GO!
AAH! AAH! WHOA!
[ LAUGHTER ]
WE'LL LET THAT ONE GO.
NO, DON'T TOUCH
YOUR ARMS DOWN!
OH, YEAH.
OKAY.
AAH!
I THOUGHT THE TWINKLE-TOES
TACTIC WOULD WORK.
APPARENTLY NOT, BECAUSE
I'M STUCK LIKE A BUG.
WITH A SCORE OF GLUE 2,
MYTHBUSTERS ZIP,
IT'S ALL DOWN TO JESSE.
JESSE HAS GOT NO SHOT AT THIS.
I'M GOING TO TRY
AND JUMP ONTO THE PLATFORM
WITHOUT FACE-PLANTING
INTO A BUNCH OF GLUE.
Narrator:
IT SOUNDS LIKE A PERFECT PLAN.
THIS IS HUMAN BUG TRAP
IN THREE, TWO, ONE.
OH!
[ LAUGHTER ]
ARE YOU ALL RIGHT?
I DON'T KNOW.
[ LAUGHTER ]
-OH!
-OH, MY GOD.
Adam: WELL, JESSE TOOK
A HUGE LEAP AT THE BEGINNING
TO, HOPEFULLY, GET FARTHER
THAN VALERIE MADE IT
ACROSS OUR BUG TRAP.
AND HE DID, [CHUCKLES]
JUST BEFORE
FACE-PLANTING INTO THE STUFF.
AND HE WAS GENUINELY CAUGHT.
UGH!
[ LAUGHTER ]
I'M STARTING TO THINK I SHOULD
GET A PAIR OF SCISSORS
AND JUST CUT YOU OUT
OF THIS SUIT FROM THE BACK.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE
A GREAT IDEA.
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY.
[ FABRIC TEARS ]
[ LAUGHTER ]
HE'S LIKE A CATERPILLAR
TURNING INTO A BUTTERFLY.
RISE!
SO, WHEN HE EMERGED
FROM THE SUIT, HE WENT, "APOOM!"
[ LAUGHTER ]
IT KIND OF SOUNDED LIKE A FART
AND AN EXPLOSION IN ONE,
JUST LIKE "POOM!"
RIGHT IN YOUR FACE.
Narrator: THERE IS NO CONTEST.
I WAS STUCK.
I WOULD HAVE DEFINITELY
BEEN STUCK.
Narrator: THE MYTHBUSTERS ARE
THREE DOWN, ALL OUT.
AND AS THEY SAY,
"THAT'S ALL, FOLKS,"
EXCEPT TO CALL THE MYTH.
I HAVE TO SAY,
I AM IMPRESSED.
THIS IS A LOT WEIRDER
AND A LOT FUNNIER
THAN I THOUGHT
IT WAS GOING TO BE.
BUT THE QUESTION IS,
HOW DO WE CALL IT?
IS IT POSSIBLE TO SUPERSIZE
A BUG TRAP AND CATCH A PERSON?
IF YOU CAME ACROSS THIS
IN SOME NORMAL STREET CLOTHES,
YOU'D BE CRYING
TO YOUR MOMMY.
YEAH, YOU GUYS ALL DID TANK
ON THE FIRST ATTEMPT, SO...
TOTALLY CONFIRMED.
I AGREE, CONFIRMED.
CONFIRMED.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S CLEAN
THIS MESS UP SOMEHOW.
♪♪